Commuting to and from work is an American pastime.
For some, it's a long drive through traffic...
...or a series of walks and subway stops.
But a very lucky few will ride to work this morning on a mountain bike.
Mountain bikes are designed to travel through the rugged terrain...
...found on mountain bike trails,...
...so by definition, they are quite durable.
Potholes, curbs, and alternate routes are no problem.
Strangely enough, the mountain bike might be the ultimate urban commuter vehicle.
They're ready for everything.
When you commute on a mountain bike, there's no such thing as traffic.
Come to think of it, you can circumvent roads altogether.